[موسيقى]
عبر التاريخ شكل تتبع الوقت ورطه بممارسه
الحياه المختلفه هاجسا لدى الامم فتم ربطه
بحركه الاجرام السماويه الى ان تم التوصل
لتقويم عصري يمكن توحيده واستخدامه حول
العالم فكيف حدث ذلك لم يعرف القدماء كم
يوما في السنه الشمسيه والشهر القمري لذلك
تضمنت المهمه الاولى لانتاج التقويم تحديد
هذه الفترات الزمنيه بالملاحظه ثم تحديدا
افضل السبل للجمع بين الايام والشهور
والسنوات وهي المهمه التي احتاجت لالاف
السنين حتى ظهور النموذج الاقرب لتقويم
الحديث والمستخدم اليوم كان هناك الكثير
من المحاولات المعاقده لقياس الوقت تتميزت
كل حضاره بطريقه تتناسب مع احتياجاتها
فاستخدم السومريون قبل الميلاد بثلاثه
الاف ومئه عام تقويما يحتوي على 12 فرشه
لان تنقسم الى 29 او 30 يوما ثم انشا
المصريون تقويما مماثلا وفقا لحركه القمر
ونجم سيريس لكن كان لديهم خمسه ايام
اضافيه في عامهم الرومان بدورهم اعتمدوا
10 اشهر فقط وكانت سنتهم
354 يوما كما اعتمدوا عددا زوجيا من
الايام لكل شهر ولذلك لم ينجح
اما تقويم البابليين تحتوي على شهر ثالث
عشر كل سنتين او ثلاث سنوات
الاغريق بدورهم تفنن باعداد التقويمات
القمريه فكان لديهم في فتره 400 قبل
الميلاد التقويم الاثني الاكثر شيوعا
والتقويمات الاولمبيه والموسميه والكونيه
والبيتونيه
في القرن الخامس قبل الميلاد
ظهر التقويم القمر الصيني الذي يدور حول
الابراج وعلم الفلك فيما اعتمد بامريكا
الوسطى تقويم المايا الذي يستند الى ان
الوقت دوري ويكرر نفسه ما يجعل اياما او
اشهر معينه مناسبه لامر ما دون غيره وكان
ينتهي هذا التقويم مع ديسمبر عام 2012
المحاوله الاهم كانت في عام 46 قبل
الميلاد حيث قدم يوليوس قيصر تقويم مدته
12 شهرا الغى الحاجه الى شهور اضافيه
بالغاء شرطي مواكبه القمر واصبح متوسط سنه
تقويميه
365.25 يوما بفضل ادراج سنه كبيسه كل اربع
سنوات لكنه اصطدم بفتره انحراف موعد تاريخ
عيد الفصح
فقام كريستوفر كلابوس بتعديل طفيف على
التقويم اليوناني بتعليمات من البابا
غريغوري الثالث عشر وهو حذف ثلاث سنوات
كبيسه كل 400 سنه وهذا هو التقويم
المستخدم اليوم
بعض التقاويم اعتمدت على المناسبات
الدينيه فهناك التقويم الاسلامي الذي يبدا
مع عامل هجره المسلمين من مكه الى المدينه
وهناك ايضا تقويم ميتون الذي يعتمد بشكل
اساسي على الاحتفال بالاعياد اليهوديه
في عام 2099 ومع نهضه الدوله السلجوقيه
اعد عمر الخيام التقويم الجلالي او الهجري
الشمسيه الذي يضم اثني عشر شهرا الاشهر
السته الاولى منه 31 يوما والخمسه التي
تليها 30 يوما اما الشهر الاخير في يكون
29 يوما في السنه البسيطه و 30 يوما في
السنه الكبيسه واعتبر هذا التقويم اكثر
دقه من سابقه لقياسه الدقيق لمده السنه
الشمسيه
اليوم وبفضل المحاولات التاريخيه الاكثر
تعقيدا بات من الممكن معرفه الوقت وتتبعه
عبر تطبيق الكتروني وباسهل الطرق
[موسيقى]